episode one of loki is kind of a
highlight reel featuring the greatest
hits of the titular character
and fans get to watch right alongside
the god of mischief himself
after the time variance authority
captures the 2012 variant version of
loki who escaped with a tesseract
during the time heist in avengers
endgame and therefore caused a branch
timeline
he's promptly put on trial luckily for
the trickster god
tva agent mobius m mobius saves him from
being reset
mobius plans to use this loki variant to
track down another dangerous variant
who's traveling through different points
in time
wreaking havoc mobius takes loki to the
25th floor of the tva headquarters
there mobius shows loki events from his
past some of which happened just
earlier that day for the trickster god
during the battle of new york
loki also gets to see events from his
future moments that the original loki
experienced but the 2012 version hasn't
gotten to yet
audiences have seen these moments since
they occurred in mcu films after the
avengers
such scenes include friega's death in
thor the dark world odin's death in
thor ragnarok and loki's own demise in
avengers infinity war
throughout this recap of loki's history
many of the people he affected in the
past appear in brief cameos in the time
theater one of these is a surprisingly
central appearance from an avengers
actress who hasn't been in the mcu since
the 2012 movie debuted
while mobius takes loki through the
events of the battle of new york via a
projector in the time theater
a few classic shots from the avengers
pop up one is set at the avengers tower
where the superhero team stares loki
down after his laws
a second avengers moment is the famous
panoramic shot of the avengers as they
stand in a circular formation on the
street during the battle in new york
in a third shot there's a brief
appearance of an avengers actress in the
theater projection
taken straight from the avengers film
there's a shot of the waitress captain
america saved during the battle
played by ashley johnson the waitress
has a small speaking role in the
avengers
when she talks to a news team expressing
her thanks to the avengers for saving
her life
the small cameo clip in loki is of the
waitress as she hides inside her
restaurant looking at the destruction
loki and his chittari army are causing
in new york city
her appearance lasts for only a few
seconds and could be easily missed if
viewers aren't paying close enough
attention
what other beloved characters might be
showing up in the series the baskin
robbins manager from ant-man
the guy who was playing galaga and
avengers
who we'll just have to keep watching to
find out
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
loki are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]